so that's my message
try to be one person whether a student
or teacher
or at least analyze why
you do change
and if like me you're looking back you
think that it was ego driven
then your journey is not completed yet
and you still have to work on your ego
and your desires and your wants
because
there's something that you still need to
do
and it's a pace perhaps that's hidden to
you
that oh Sensei was trying to give us
but we miss the point and we missed the
whole essence of his Aikido
and the part we thought we obtained we
perhaps never obtained it at all
we only obtained
the youth the ego and the want and
desire to prove
to others that we were
good
in everything we done
rather than
humble
not old
still can be 20 years of age here
in your mind
but humble and considerate considering
and when looking at your students
training together
try to help them
to become
less eager minded
and more compassionate
and we may be able to get these people
to their goal faster than we got to ours
thank you for your time